mario striker's battle league is coming
out on june 10th for the nintendo switch
so ahead of its release we decided to
take a look at just what exactly is
going on and the plumber's latest gaming
adventure and why everyone is battling
on a soccer pitch be sure to like the
vid and sub to the channel if you want
to stay up to date in the gaming space
now here's everything you need to know
about mario striker's battle leak
so right off the bat for those new to
mario strikers the game is part of a
series going back to the original game
for the nintendo gamecube the series
basically has mario and the usual
friends and enemies alike duking it out
through the world's most popular sport
soccer now this is not the latest fifa
or paz uh sorry e football game and for
those looking for a genuinely authentic
feeling soccer sim mario striker's
battle league will not strike that itch
but man if this game doesn't look like a
wacky good time now let's take a look at
the gameplay in its premise the shocking
and out-of-left-field violence is
honestly hilarious but just take a look
at any of the trailers and it's pretty
funny watching these characters low-key
try to murder each other all in the name
of sporting competition when i say that
the game literally encourages behavior
that would put zidane and the entire
national french soccer team of 2006 to
shame i'm being dead serious as if
that's not wild enough as is the field
itself looks like it's got electric
boundaries that you can tackle your
opponent into zapping them and leaving
them completely stunned lucky for us
though the game sees no such issue and
it doesn't implement any fouls turning
mario's soccer league looking more like
a rugged street pickup game and the back
alleys where bowser probably's got a lot
of money at stake anyone who has ever
played mario party or mario kart is
pretty well familiar with items and how
these items can be used to give
themselves an advantageous boost or to
wreck their opponents usually in pretty
hilarious ways that mechanic is also
present in mario strikers and it all
ties back into the tackling i mentioned
earlier although if you were just
trucking your opponent left and right
don't expect to also get a bunch of
items because as fun as that sounds it's
not exactly fair is it that's why
players who just got rocked will have
the benefit of receiving items to give
them a fair shot the game's got a
distinct flair and personality to it
even in the stadium selection the
stadiums are often two different arenas
just smashed together at the midfield
line making a functional hybrid of both
now the fields themselves might be
different in their size but the
difference is usually very minor the
main draw though is watching the huge
landmasses crash into each other before
the players take the field ready to
embarrass their opponents the core
gameplay loop is more similar to
something you'd see in fifa street or
volta mode than a full 11v11 match in
mario strikers you've got a steady
roster of 10 characters to choose from
to play in four v4 matches each
character will have different stats such
as power or speed with characters like
princess peach being on the lighter side
and huge bruisers like bowser or wario
having far more power but at the expense
of being much slower you can pass and
shoot as well as take some detours
towards question blocks that appear on
the field really what distinguishes the
gameplay from a regular soccer match are
special shots that players can take
after a team has built up enough power
consider these shots like the blue
shells of mario strikers but with more
skill involved activating a special shot
brings up a swinging meter similar to
those that you might have seen in mario
golf games if you pull a perfectly timed
shot an unblockable shot launches across
the field guaranteeing you a score don't
worry though if you missed the timing
window you could still potentially make
the shot but it is possible for the
other team to stop it truthfully these
special moves look varied too each
highlighting a character's unique trait
and they're also a really cool visual
flourish like a final smash almost
showing off elements of the sketchy ink
style that appears in the official
artwork the characters post goal
celebrations as seen through cinematic
and replay cameras all add extra flair
and they're a fun touch now since the
roster is fairly thin at 10 characters
there's a great emphasis on gear to help
add more playstyle variety like the
special shots the different gear are
nice visual touches that factor in a
character's style and traits mario's
headgear for example are a series of
different armor takes on his iconic hat
each with a stat boost so you can tweak
your player to your liking now this
seems to be where the game's economy
comes most into play since the way that
you get new gear is by paying with coins
now getting coins is simple just play
the game customization also extends a
bit to your soccer club too with things
like different fence posts and
decorations managing your club is part
of the backdrop of competitive play as
you'll make your own club identity by
picking a logo from a series of icons
background shields and colors now if all
this sounds good to you and you decide
to take the plunge nintendo has
announced plans for multiple free
content drops such as additional
characters post launch mario striker's
battle league will release on june 10th
for nintendo switch
now be sure to stick to game spot for
all things gaming and if you're a
nintendo fan keep an eye out for my
coverage of pokemon violin and scarlet
coming up as well as our breath of the
wild expert max breaking down elite
combat tips and a bunch of things that
you didn't know that's it for me until
next time
[Applause]
[Music]
you